zielinski who's played a very very tough
set of cards extremely well in terms of
keeping Western support I don't think
the Americans or the NATO allies would
particularly wish to be associated with
the Ukraine attacking the Kremlin the
heart of Moscow so although I could see
that being a short-term morale boost of
the ukrainians I think the long-term
strategy would be too bad
but for Putin I think with as I say the
war going badly a counter-offensive
coming the feeling that you need to say
to the Russian people why we continue to
need to make the sacrifice look at these
terrorists they're trying to attack me
personally I need to you know turn this
into an even greater National effort to
kill zelenski crush the ukrainians
denarcify it feeds into that sort of
narrative and that seems more plausible
to me than the benefits that zielinski
could do in in operating that